yo can you tell somebody turn the music  up please  hey can we turn the music up no but i  want you to make a statement here  set the tone you know what i'm saying  and we only gave up 25 points  keep guarding it's all how we start this  quarter they played game seven two days  ago  it's all how we start this quarter shots  fall shots don't fall  keep being the monster this is where  it's at what i'm saying  you just keep getting your mind right  and it overcomes everything just like  you're doing  okay let's go do it on d it'll happen on  o we ain't gonna get nothing the next  four sorry  ain't gonna get nothing the next four  stay locked in up here  heck of a way to start that western  conference semi-final  [Music]  one of our teammates right there the  great dwyane wade